Next number, please!
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon, sir.
What can I do for you today?
I'd like to open up an account here, please.
Certainly, sir.
What sort of account are you looking to open?
I want to open up a checking account.
Okay, do you want an unlimited checking account, or a fixed monthly checking account?
What is the difference?
With an unlimited checking account, you can write as many checks as you like every month.
Is there a monthly fee with that account?
You need to maintain a minimum balance of one thousand dollars.
Okay, so as long as I maintain the minimum balance, there's no fee.
I think that would work out better for me.
Let's go that route.